rappelez moi comment il s'appelle
[Musique]
infinity ward a totalement détruit le
game et posé les bases thanos a gagné
avengers infinity ward est un film qui
restera dans l'histoire du cinéma
néanmoins ce dernier n'est que
l'introduction du prologue des 22 films
du mca avengers 4 ou probablement
avengers annihilation en sera la
véritable fin le point final de
l'histoire
actuellement nous savons encore que très
peu de choses sur l'opus final de la
phase iii du mc eu
et justement suite à de nombreuses
réflexions j'ai imaginé une théorie
concernant l'intrigué total d'avengers 4
il est obligé que la mort de thanos et
le retour de nos héros doit être la
conclusion de toute l'histoire
ceci est le but ultime mais à travers la
plupart des théories que nous retrouvons
sur youtube
je trouve que nous n'avons pas assez
creusé la question thanos a disparu
suite à la disparition de la moitié des
êtres vivants de l'univers ce dernier se
cachent sur une planète déserte à l'abri
de tous pour y passer des jours
tranquilles
il est actuellement impossible de
retrouver thanos et ce détail est très
important les avengers ne peuvent pas
juste retrouver la noce et le gant de
l'infini avec les pierres une autre
approche se doit arriver le voyage dans
le temps est une quasi certitude
on pourrait même enlevé le quasi chaque
héros sera de retour dans le film
d'avengers 4 nous en avons la preuve
avec les déclarations de plusieurs
acteurs comme par exemple sebastian stan
qui a décrit une scène où tous les héros
étaient réunis où il voyait hank pym aux
côtés de captain marvel par exemple et
cetera
bref que des héros qui ne se sont jamais
rencontrés auparavant mais ceux ci ne
s'adresse pas seulement aux héros des
méchants seront également de retour
car les acteurs font partie du casting
l'eau qui sera par exemple présent mais
surtout est le plus important pour moi
c'est le retour de cross bones un retour
qui va accentuer fortement ma théorie
enfin plusieurs photos des avengers ou
autres personnages
d'anciens costumes ont fuité genre à un
captain america sans barbe en costume
moulant comme dans le tout premier
avengers
sans oublier évidemment l'ouverture
qu'apporte ant man et la guêpe avec les
vortex dans le champ quantique
bref le voyage dans le temps est une
certitude mais à quoi pourrait-il bien
servir comme je le disais l'intrigué
plus subtil qu'on ne pense thanos est
introuvable
ainsi que le gant avec les pierres et
même si les avengers le retrouver
comment inverser la donne
il est totalement loin d'être sûr que le
gant peut inverser le processus surtout
qu'il est actuellement bien amoché et
surtout nous serons supposément quelques
années après les événements dignes
finity war l'intriguent réellement
intéressante serait donc que nos héros
retourne dans le passé afin d'éviter la
réussite de thanos et donc de l'empêcher
ou bien de récupérer les pierres avant
lui une multitude de possibilités
s'offre à nous en vrai
cependant il faut penser aux
conséquences de tout ça déjà le voyage
dans le temps est quelque chose de très
particulier et compliqué à maîtriser
dans l'histoire du cinéma nous avons
deux exemples concrets du voyage dans le
temps le premier on va dire se base sur
le destin prenons l'exemple d'un
incendie qui a fait des ravages
énorme vous retournerez d'en passer pour
empêcher l'acte d'arrivée mais vous vous
rendrez compte au final que vos actions
feront en sorte que l' incendie arrive
bref peu importe ce que vous ferez tout
est déjà prêt destiné à arriver en fait
dans le deuxième cas de figure celui qui
fonctionne le mieux pour avengers c'est
le voyage dans le temps à la retour vers
le futur en gros vous retourner dans le
passé vous modifier quelque chose et le
futur en sera modifiée en conséquence
c'est le cas de figure qui fonctionne le
mieux ici tout est déjà prêt destiné
pourquoi introduire les voyages
temporels
c'est juste une question de logique en
fait mais le plus important et c'est là
où je pense qu'on ne se rend pas assez
compte de la chose c'est que du coup
tout est absolument modifiable nos chers
avengers vont certainement se mettre à
la recherche des pierres avant que
thanos ne les trouve du coup les pierres
ont été introduites dans tous les films
précédents infinity ward et cela
expliquerait pourquoi le retour de
certains personnages dans le film où les
photos leakées nous arrivons
dernier film le point final du mc eu et
quoi de mieux pour conclure la série
qu'un voyage entre chaque film de
l'univers avengers un captain america
first avenger ce avengers et joe
filtrons les gardiens de la galaxie
vous n'imaginez pas tout ce que le
voyage dans le temps peut impliquer
je prends un exemple très simple je vous
parlais que le retour de cross bones
était un gros arguments pour ma théorie
est bien pourquoi cela son retour
signifie que les avengers vont retourner
à l'époque de civil war et le soldat de
l'hiver puisque le personnage n'apparaît
que dans ces deux films et donc éviter
son kamikaze un des terribles actes qui
ont fait la naissance des accords de
soko vie et on peut aller très loin
comme ça l'état par amant supposé que
les avengers retournerais jusqu'à
l'époque d'avengers 1
c'est ce qui est le plus sûr vu les
photos soient une époque vraiment
lointaine on retourne dans le passé à
travers les anciens films pour récupérer
les pierres avant la noce noah ventures
peuvent éviter ce qu'ils ont déjà vécu
les erreurs faites la guerre contre
l'occident avengers un la naissance
d'ultra le suicide crossbones
développement d'hydra dans le shield
donc éviter tout le bazar des accords de
soko vie bref amener un futur meilleur
100 morts inutiles et sans erreur
j'ai d'ailleurs envie de vous amener un
autre argument qui va en faveur de cette
théorie
quelles sont exactement les héros
restant après le claquement de doigts de
thanos tort tony stark black widow
banner captain america nebula et
requêtes requête est encore présent
alors oui vous allez me dire comme mon
bon vieux aéronefs marvel ne pouvait
quand même pas tuer tous les gardiens de
la galaxie dans infinity ward alors je
suis d'accord mais j'ai une autre
explication plus sensée requête est
présent pour une bonne raison
alors c'est théorique tout ça n'oubliez
pas mais si nos héros doivent retourner
dans le passé pour prendre les pierres
avant la noce
ils auront besoin d'au moins un gardien
de la galaxie la pierre du pouvoir est à
mener pour la première fois dans le
premier volet des gardiens de la galaxie
et et garder auprès des cohortes de nova
sur xen d'art seul un gardien de la
galaxie peut avoir cette information
ils l'ont même toucher chaque personnage
restant sait où se trouve au moins une
pierre vous allez me dire que personne à
part gamme aura est un os ça
où se trouve la pierre de l'âme et bien
marvel a évidemment tout prévu les amis
nebula sera là pour certainement guidé
tony stark sur terre ce dernier étant
coincé seul sur titan laisser les bulles
a inclus une facilité scénaristique mais
pas que nebula étaient présentes canga
mort a annoncé où se trouvait la pierre
de l'âme elle était torturé devant
camorra par thanos je le répète chaque
personnage reste en possède
l'information sur où se trouve au moins
une pierre c'est une vision vraiment
rose que je vous ai proposé là néanmoins
je pense vraiment que cela peut arriver
mais pas sans conséquences évidemment
thanos ne va certainement pas se laisser
faire et va sûrement se rendre compte
des actions de nos héros après tout
thanos will return souris est d'ailleurs
toujours présentes vision peut être
reconstruit et vivre entre guillemets
sans la pierre chris evans a aussi
annoncé son nom retour chez marvel sur
twitter et tony stark est également un
point plus qu'important dans le plan de
doctor strange
bref une multitude de mystère est encore
présent et comptez sur moi pour essayer
de vous apporter des explications
alors n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à me
laisser un petit pouce bleus et surtout
me laisser un petit commentaire sur ces
questions sans réponse j'attends vos
amis vous pouvez également me suivre sur
twitter où me soutenir financièrement
sur une type en regardant quelques
publicités
bref c'était argot rock et que le
lyonnais heures soit avec vous
[Musique]